hello there hi videogame chums it's that
time of year again December which means
it's time to pick my top 5 video games
of the year this year was a great year
for video games so you may not like
everything that's on my list you may not
like the order the order of the games
the order is not in my top life believe
me but at the end of the day I hope we
can still be friends
number 5 is project cars
market cars the most enjoyable racing
game I fade in a long long long long
time it's a game that was created by car
fans it was like Craig developed and you
can see because it's a game it doesn't
have all the licenses but what it does
have is a access to a breath of really
interesting racing disciplines a host of
tracks that sort of run the gamut from
like small sort of trucks you can do
track days on to you know big Formula
One famous locations there's so many
different ways to play the races they
have the career mode in there but they
also just let you kind of just [ __ ]
about and pick whatever you want right
out of the gate and it also controls
incredibly well the cars feel great they
feel realistic and it also has the best
wheel support I think for any game that
came out this year I think it goes a
long way that like I love playing the f1
games over here but I thought driving in
Formula a as its owner project cars was
more fun and realistic in that game than
playing the licence that one game number
four on my list is Metal Gear Solid 5
it reminds me of other games like
infamous and just cause this is gonna
sound so dumb but like those are games
like just play because I just love
clearing out bases I just love going
around the map and checking them all off
one by one but it's like that game but
also a game that's got like incredible
emerging gameplay moments really good
combat and stealth mechanics and also
interesting missions so it's kind of
marries the really like dumb open-world
jauntiness of those type of games with
like actually a good meth liquor selling
game and I think it's a sign of a really
good game when you go back and replay
levels even if you've completed it and
although the game forces you to do that
in the second half I actually really
enjoyed doing that and the first half
and doing all the signups it's it's a
great game and I'm looking forward to
playing more over the Christmas break on
2016 my third favorite game of the year
is hidden inside of this box what could
it be
[Music]
my third favorite game of the year is
fallout 4 or as I like to call this
fallout more because it's really not all
that different to Fallout New Vegas it's
a big crazy open-world full of
interesting side quests stuff to shoot
and characters to meet but in many ways
it does involve on sort of the I guess
the worst part of games like poetry new
Vegas number one being the shooting
shooting a 4/4 is actually tons of fun
be it with pistols or automatic weapons
or the big boy stuff you can actually
play that game outside of flats which is
a bit of a bit of a relief and the other
thing it does really well in comparison
to your games is environmental diversity
the old games and I've got back and
played both this year completed both
this year they're very you know
monochromatic you know we go north south
east west in a direction and it's not
all that different and the wonderful
thing about fallout 4 is that it's it's
first of all is a huge huge map but
there's also lots of like interesting
stuff there there are big cities which
you know fans have wanted for for a long
long time there is all sort of usual
wasteland you stuff up in the north is
really interesting you know nuclear area
in the south and then there's like you
know three or four or five different
towns that sort of all have their own
thing going on it's weird thinking that
it's not all that difference to the
third game but it's still my third game
of the year I think that probably says
as much of how much I love just fall out
as a game as much as the quality of this
particular game yo Chris kicked this
ball
rocky underwater
I like playing football with my mates
and rocket league is essentially a game
about playing football where you mate
I think goes a long way when I
considered that I actually haven't
played much FIFA at all since rocket Lee
came at its fill that gap it's not just
a great team based game it's not just a
great like weird digital download game
it's also the best football or soccer a
game I've played in years it feels like
when you're playing football it feels
like you are trying to manipulate this
this body instead of it being your foot
or your leg it's a car to hit the ball
at the right spot and you're trying to
make sure it gets the right trajectory
to where it goes and then it also has
that great thing about playing football
which is you're one part of a theme team
and you want to make sure that you're
like playing your part that you're in
the right position that you're like you
know supporting your your team mates so
in that way if there's more like a
actual game of football or soccer than
FIFA or pro Evolution Soccer ever did
and that's why rocket League is my
second favorite game of 2015 I love
exploring digital wars that feel real
lots of worlds look real but they don't
feel necessarily like the real places
and for me the witcher 3 wild hunt in
the world of the crops it's huge huge
world feels more real than anywhere I've
ever been before
side quests seem to blend into the
secondary quests and the second request
seem to blend into the main quest and
then the main quest
propagates out into other quests in a
way that like feels completely organic
it doesn't feel like oh I'm making these
decisions I'm gonna select a because I
want to be in seeing DNA and F which is
the way a lot of games work is that
you're sort of planning your way ahead
and The Witcher you're kind of making
decisions from your gut because you know
you can't really figure out what's going
to happen next and then you couple that
with some incredibly written stories
like side quests that you may never run
into that you then suddenly you you're
like three hours deep on and then a
combat system that at least on the
harder difficulties is super engaging
and interesting and invites you to sort
of play around with abilities and styles
and then just a massive massive world
like I remember playing 40 hours in like
the area read the bloody baron and then
going at the scale occur like oh my god
how long is this game when I finished
that it was a it turns out the game was
at least 120 hours for me I loved it it
is the best open-world role-playing game
I have ever played and I am not done
with it and that's why that's my
favorite game of 2015
[Music]
[Music]